the Trump Russia scandal is now
undeniably beyond any doubt directly
involving Donald Trump personally
involvement in the lies has now reached
the President of the United States when
we saw that email chain related to Trump
juniors meeting with the Russian lawyer
in Trump Tower for the purposes of
obtaining dirt on Hillary Clinton we had
for the first time in writing
confirmation of the intent to collude
with Russia for the benefit of Trump to
the detriment of Hillary Clinton
however we were told at the time that
Donald Trump was personally not involved
at all and we were specifically told by
Trump's lawyer Jay Sekulow a number of
times that the statement which we now
know was riddled with inaccuracies some
people would call them lies that Donald
Trump jr. and his lawyer put that
statement together that the President of
the United States was not at all
involved in that statement we received
which was a lie it was an inaccurate
statement from Trump jr. here is Jay
Sekulow Trump's lawyer in no uncertain
terms on Meet the Press saying nope
Trump was not involved in that statement
so I read those reports as well and the
president was not did not draft the
response the response and which came
from Donald Trump jr. I'm sure in
consultation with his lawyer so that is
where that statement again I think it's
important understood when the
information as the information was to be
released a few days later but as the
information became public our
understanding is my understanding is
that the Donald Trump jr. and his lawyer
worked on a statement to make regarding
the scope of the meeting and the scope
of the meeting that what was discussed
at the meeting actually ended up being
more about the Majin ski act than
anything else
okay so Chuck Todd is actually smart
here he says okay well hold on forget
about whether he drafted it that's very
specific language you're using was he
involved in it and Jay Sekulow is still
adamant that Trump wasn't involved okay
part two yeah you really what this was
about were very careful to say the
president didn't draft a statement that
isn't what I asked did the president get
a heads-up on the statement did he sign
off on the statement did was he asked to
read the statement before it was given
the New York Times on Air Force One
I mean I can't say whether the president
was told to say
be coming from the Sun on that I don't
have that I didn't have that
conversation and let me let me say this
the president I do want to be clear the
president was not involved in the
drafting of the statement it did not
issue the statement it came from Donald
Trump jr. so that that's what I can tell
you four days before that interview on
ABC's Good Morning America with George
Stephanopoulos another conversation
which we will put the transcript of up
on the screen for you where George
Stephanopoulos said that does raise
another set of questions because the New
York Times is reporting this morning the
President signed off on the initial
statement on Saturday on the initial
statement from Don Jr on Saturday but
didn't mention the emails didn't really
go into any great detail on the meeting
in fact was misleading about the meeting
so the President signed off on that
statement does he feel he was misled by
his son and by Jared Kushner if indeed
they didn't tell him about these emails
that they both received and Sekulow
responded the president didn't sign off
on anything he was coming back from the
g20 summit the statement that was
released on Saturday was released by
Donald Trump jr. and I'm sure in
consultation with his lawyers the
president wasn't involved in that
Stephanopoulos continued well the New
York Times says that he was involved in
it that several people on the plane were
involved in it as well
so you're disputing and seculow
interrupts that's incorrect well we have
now learned that was all a lie on the
flight home from the g20 meeting in
Germany Donald Trump personally dictated
the statement in which Donald Trump jr.
said they were talking only about
Russian kids which we now know was a
straight-up bold-faced lie and even Jay
Sekulow attempts to wordsmith a
technically true statement failed
because if you dictate a statement
you're verbally drafting the statement
period and this of course in and of
itself is not a crime but it's another
attempt pad to hide the truth about
contacts with Russia and this was a lie
that came straight from the horse's
mouth Donald Trump is personally
involved in the lies now and it sounds
like all of the other advisers on Air
Force One with them wanting to just get
the whole story out to be
in with knowing that the New York Times
could use that trip trip method and gash
them in a bunch of lies right instead
Trump went with this method which caught
Don junior his own son in four or five
different lives there so I mean that's
just not very political politically
savvy is it oh absolutely not and think
about how far it's gone right there was
no meeting well the meeting happened but
it was about Russian adoption and
Hillary dirt was never mentioned well
the meeting happened and hillary dirt
was promised but it wasn't actually
provided but Trump senior wasn't
involved in any statements about it -
well the meeting happened and the
pretense was hillary dirt and donald
trump did come up with a statement about
the meeting which turned out to be a lie
but there's nothing to see here because
no crime was committed and in all of
this were supposed to believe the guy
who came up with a statement about what
happened at a meeting that he supposedly
knew nothing about remember that that at
the core of this is still the assertion
that Trump senior didn't know about the
meeting that hasn't yet been disproven
although it seems incredibly unlikely
why would someone who has no idea about
this meeting be dictating a statement
about it that also doesn't make any
sense and if this meeting was just a
nothing burger as Reince Priebus said
and they actually just talked about
Russian adoption the whole time
why would Trump even care to hide it up
yeah that's the thing if you have
nothing to hide why are you constantly
lying and deceiving and I don't remember
who came up with this term at first but
I think stupid Watergate is a good term
not all right that was John Oliver okay
the revelations have sort of been
working their way all the way up to the
top of the food chain and it's really
sort of the hubris and stupidity that
could end up being Donald Trump's
downfall he seems to genuinely think no
one can figure out his lies period no
one can touch him and the more he talks
the worse it seems to get the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as $1 per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad